it was a much-loved script relic from
from when it was first came out and and
and and people read it in Hollywood it
had a lot of fans and it did have a lot
of humor we worked you know quite a
hard-on reworking the beginning and the
end of the tough you know doing a movie
with a narrator you think is a kind of
blessing because it gives you some
flexibility and it would be able to
nudge this and the others actually you
know it's quite a cross to bear because
it means that you can rewrite it and
then you can keep on rewriting it and
then you can rewrite it some more and
that was certainly the passage of
post-production the contradiction of the
script and the movie is in a funny way
the premise and I think especially for
an American audience is quite
troublesome or dark people call it but
the movie was never meant to be dark
it's you know it's not brooding and it's
not it's not introspective and it's not
edgy you know in many ways it was a sort
of had a schematic feel to me it's a
element of fairy tale about it you know
it's not you know Oliver Platts
character Terry when he finds out about
his daughter and his best friend you
know he goes to play Ultimate Frisbee
it's not a conventional you know to a
social realist piece and whether or not
one could you know I you want you wanted
it the character experiences to be
sincere and you wanted the emotional
truth to you know not just be a sort of
a pastiche or a cartoon and yet you know
from the beginning you know when Steve
and I first talked about me talk about
how the movie should look and all of
that I was like it has to be funny you
know I think we wouldn't stand alone as
a character study we had to make it
funny and with luck it would be touching
as well because the themes of it for me
what attracted me I thoughts a film
about forgiveness and about not judging
people and and about understanding the
frailty of human behavior that we can
all make mistakes and somehow through
the kind of trickiness of life and the
chaotic elements of life we can come
through stronger that was you know that
was what the meaning of the movie for me
I mean I have a theory of film is kind
of strained which is I think
as a physicality that like a brushstroke
on canvas or like a bronze of a
sculpture or something that it it
implies an object in a medium and so you
can almost feel like you touch it this
there's a physicality from the grain you
know in the shake and all those things
that people say they don't like and the
problem for me with digital is it's like
the only medium that tries to pretend it
doesn't even exist and you're just left
with the image of the face as opposed to
the face as rendered in paint as
rendered in bronze is rendered in grain
and so it's like a while it looked like
it was always too sharp or too soft and
it's a lot of weight for the image to
have and I love text from kind of i love
texture and all things but in the last
year or two things have really changed
in terms of what you can get with a
digital camera and so i think most
intimate ogron's would say that up until
the advent of the cameras that everybody
shouldn't even now and i may be shooting
with like in a month you know there was
a real resistance among cinematographers
to most of what digital was presenting
but i think now it's it's kind of now it
becomes more question of taste that
there is there's great qualities and
advantages in some ways to digital in
some to film and it's it's a question of
taste and i just did a film this year
earlier this year in film and it was
done for a micro-budget all the things
people say you can't do you know shoot
film on a little budget we did it and it
was great and so hopefully it would be
it can go back to being a creative
choice and it won't you know kind of
disappear prematurely it was meant to be
just the values surrounding suburbia you
know not urban and you know and by that
i mean it wasn't you know dark and edgy
had a always talking about it as having
a trying to have a kind of purity of
spirit and we shot it in a very
straightforward way for to make the
comedy play and to feel the characters
and to make it a kind of you know rich
enough warm enough not threatening kind
of thing but all those judgments are at
the beginning when we were looking at
the locations once it houses to be now
ice but in want it to be too nice tanned
wanted to be a film about rich people
you know nothing toning it was just you
know it could be anywhere thing I
thought the relationships in the story
you know felt you know and I'm an
outsider obviously it felt to me the
universe so we all have friends that we
grew up with because our parents are
best friends and at some point you make
your divide with that you know will
recognize slightly smothering mothers
and fathers who are best friends you
know and who kind of like the potting
shed and hanging out like men do and
those kind of things I was we were just
trying you know to kind of keep the
universal in mind